are going to get lots of women for today
and they will wonder why don't they want
me forever because you've got a high
body count
because this is where you are yeah
because I don't suppose that when you
decide to get your partner would you
feel great about her going out in skimpy
clothes and drinking tequila and dancing
on tables you have a problem with that
you would listen listen this is my view
I said this earlier I do listen if I
trust her and she trusts me there's a
mutual trust between us I do not if
she's going to cheat she's going to
cheat we're not talking about you let me
say this if she's got a table with her
friends and there's another geezers
table I don't care yeah why does it care
I don't care where you go I don't care
who you're with as long as you're not
no